[Musique]
car les enfants qu'on jouera au je vais
te poser une question et vous allez me
répondre par oui ou par non ne
trouvez-vous pas que je suis
magnifiquement superbe ou superbement
magnifique avec ma tenue de grands
chasseurs à merci je savais que vous
aviez très bon goût voyez-vous pour
m'acheter cette tenue de chasseur il a
fallu que je casse ma tirelire mais ça
en valait la peine
savez vous à quoi sert le le foulard que
j'ai sur la tête
ces sables pour me protéger du soleil
exactement et cette paire de jumelles
[Musique]
c'est pour guetter mon gibier c'est ça
et et la gourde voyez awards
exactement oui et savez-vous quel genre
de gibier j'aurais attrapé
exactement des papillons oui alors ça va
se passer comme ça lorsque je verrai pas
un beau papillon je vais lui courir
après et la trappe et hop je soulèverai
mon fils un je le prendrais délicatement
dans mes doigts pour ne pas l'abîmer je
lui dirai bonjour petit papillon jeu
contemplerait ces magnifiques couleurs
chatoyantes et puis je lui dirai au
revoir bateau et je le laisserais
s'envoler voilà parce que je pense que
un papillon est beaucoup mieux à voler
librement dans la nature plutôt qu'être
aveugle et derrière une vitre 1 c'est
vrai bon si vous voulez venir à la
chasse avec moi suivez moi
et vous me dites si vous voyez des
papillons à regarder bien
regardez bien au delà ryan à
l'apparation
raté sa terriens allons un peu plus loin
regardez bien
on va la voir celui là
je lai
allons-y doucement
cette fois on va la voir un samu l'a pas
bien les enfants ou allez vous comme ça
chez ces pavillons way chasse aux
papillons mais c'est très bien c'est une
très bonne idée mais vous êtes tout
essoufflé lors asseyez-vous un petit peu
la roma et reposez vous faites les
enfants
c'est un insecte tonnelle tenez regardez
ce que nous attend justement casimir oh
là là poursuit la foule énorme alors
il a 4 l
amy conduite la microscopie ça qui lui
donne un éclat et une couleur
incomparable
les antennes
et comment se nourrir
licite mais dans les leurs il le prend
au milieu des fleurs la spire le suc des
fleurs grâce à sa trompe
mais non casimir voilà pourquoi aussi
des antennes qui lui sert à communiquer
avec nous pour la les deux antennes
c'est comme ça avec eux de sa naissance
à sa mort le papillon subi beaucoup de
transformations
je dis qu'on appelle aussi une larme là
la chenille son tour de soi
devient une crise et enfin
un très beau papillon et non
malheureusement il a eu une existence
éphémère il ne vit pas très longtemps
bon les enfants je crois que casimir 20
octobre je souhaite une bonne chasse aux
papillons merci françois bon merci on va
continuer à j'en ai vu par là bas
suivez-moi regard des progrès là bas on
va avoir tenu là on y va qu'elle
diminuerait les enfants ont été chassés
les papillons dans les champs ils en ont
de la chance moi j'ai toujours du
travail bonjour bonjour à musulmane mais
elles chuté ça me fait plaisir de vous
voir vous je m'ennuyais un peu tout seul
eh bien je boirai volontiers une double
grenade cas de non et je vous sers long
non julie aujourd'hui c'est moi qui fais
certes un bon si ça vous amuse alors
tant mieux
et
vous comprendrez vous est bien la même
chose que vous ah bon bah voilà merci
roue juliet ce que je peux vous poser
une petite question
comment faites vous pour avoir les
cheveux si joliment river perd rien du
tout il frise naturellement pourquoi aux
écoutes et roger moore est tellement à
voir mais je faisais comme l'evo
renault de bruit mais dites moi comment
faire eh bien écoutez d'abord il faut
qu'ils soient plus courts parce que ça
n'irait pas cette longueur là il faut
l'écouter un petit peu et puis après
vous mettez des papillotes pour les
frisés
ou j'aimerais beaucoup essayé
oui mais si ça ne va pas ça c'est un
risque à courir et bien tant pis je le
prends julie pouvait vous vous chargez
du travail
oui mais alors mais alors je ne vous
garantit pas le résultat en bon
tant pis allons-y tandem bon eh bien
nous y
voilà
[Musique]
voilà il ne reste plus qu'à poser une
papillote après vous pourrez allez vous
allonger au soleil tranquillement
attendre que ça sèche après vous retirer
les papillotes il vous serez frisé comme
un mouton
oh merci mille fois j
mais où vais je me m eh bien là par
exemple je crois que c'est là que le
soleil est le plus fort oh oui oh et
l'endroit est charmant
et je crois même que je vais en profiter
pour faire une petite sieste ah bon
alors je vous laisse à tout à l'heure
tout à l'heure j'ai dit merci
on a fait une belle promenade n'est ce
pas il n'y avait pas tellement papillon
aujourd'hui je trouve non écoutez je
vous laisse je vais quand même jeté un
dernier coup d'oeil là bas voir si par
hasard il y en avait quelques-uns ça
alors c'était le nom 1 2 3 4 8 8 et 4 12
12 papillon dans le buisson là-bas en
live pour que je les attrape ceux ci
attention
deux trois
ans que ça qu'est ce qui se passe
alors par un buisson qui parla avec la
voix de mademoiselle futaie c'est
curieux mais mes chaînes sur gazon je
suis effectivement il mais [ __ ] mais
quasiment me veux-tu retirer
immédiatement ce film ma tête aura pas
avant d'avoir parlé avec les papillons
qui sont sur votre tête coutu tu veux
parler avec les papillons mais tu es
devenu complètement fou non non non pas
papillon papillon on dit papillon mais
lyon casimir ce faux pas des papillons
ce sont des papillotes ou bien enfin
mais qu'est ce que c'est alors les
papillons la des papillotes ce sont des
morceaux de papier dont on se sert pour
enrouler les cheveux afin de les frises
et voilà vous êtes sûr que ce ne sont
pas des papillons mais oui mais puisque
je me tiens de répéter leur maintenant
casimir enlèvement hassan ma tête si le
taboulé ou encore
mademoiselle [ __ ] oui contre la
prochaine fois
au lieu de mettre des papillotes sur
votre tête est bien mettez des papillons
c'est quand même plus joli occasion